all right thank you all for coming
tonight this is this group is bio
captive a
putting ourselves together as a
non-profit think tank type entity that I
will start hosting some salons and
gatherings and we really want people to
imagine what science could be and we
want to know people to know what science
is and what it could be because so much
of our future is based upon you know
scientific discoveries engineering of
those discoveries for practical uses by
society if the last century featured the
Industrial Revolution and then the
silicon revolution probably a biology
revolution is going to be what creates
so much of what humanity uses and enjoys
and eats and and thrives with in the
next 50 or 100 years so we firmly
believe that but we also think that
there hasn't been enough 10 attention
given to the culture that drives the
training and development of scientists
and the Selective pressures that help
determine who goes into science and who
stays in it and we want first of all
everyone to become aware of these
selective pressures and then think about
how maybe we can change the narrative
and how we can educate and train
scientists differently and how
scientists can interact with the public
differently and more and above all that
the public can begin to conceive of
itself as a group of scientists because
every day even when we cook things we're
testing hypotheses and so we are all
scientists and we're going to be called
upon to make public policy decisions as
a group it is more important than ever
that we all conceive of ourselves as
scientists but then also think about
what does it mean to be a professional
scientists and what are the Selective
pressures and how can we change address
and it change these narratives and so
today we have a great panel of people
whose life and work touches upon science
and all its forms philosophy education
art and everyone here is a scientists
and or an educator and we're an artist
and or a philosopher and we want to
have them talk a little bit about the
issues that I just mentioned and and
they're unique and interesting
experiences and perspectives so I'd like
to introduce the panelists and we can go
ahead and get started so I myself I'm
Luis Metzger I formerly worked in Big
Pharma I know I'm the CSO of a start-up
I'm a biochemist lipid biochemist and a
bacteriologist by training and have done
other things but I really support bio
captivates mission and would it's my
pleasure to help moderate this panel and
introduce our guests so Nick of the long
now foundation is a director of a
longtime director at the long now and is
a systems engineer by training but is
also a deep thinker and philosopher by
self-guided education and and through
his work which involves interaction with
you know sort of the the most
cutting-edge thinkers of our times I
would say and and speaking of the
culture of science the long now
foundation really cares about thinking
and planning for deep time so what if
the world isn't going to end at our own
hands in the next 50 or a hundred years
and we have to think about what 10,000
years of humanity's future looks like
that is a large part of what the long
now is encouraging us to think about
Robin is here with us she's the chief
experience officer of the Minerva
project and the Minerva project is a
four-year undergraduate university now
also a graduate has a graduate program
in data science I believe and Minerva is
radically different than a lot of for
your educational programs that probably
we've all been through and it's focused
on first principle thinking the training
of students first and foremost how to
use logic and how to use statistics and
how to think and and be very questioning
of
the data that they receive and how they
interpret it and I because of a great
talk that Robin gave maybe three years
ago I became aware of the Minerva
project and so it's great to have you
here
fadna is how do I see your company's
name fairness fairness yeah Farren him
not fair and I'm fat now is a PhD
biochemist whose work in founding her
startup is really interesting because it
looks at how small organisms nematodes
communicate with each other and interact
with the soil microbiome and yes soil
does have a microbiome not just the
human gut and with all sorts of
implications for agriculture and how we
feed the world
with the coming climate change and so
many other selective pressures and talk
to her in the happy hour afterward about
her company's collaboration with NASA
they are about to do experiments in
space so June is a investor and science
director here at Indy bio we'd like to
thank for letting us host this event
here and June has a really interesting
career arc she did her PhD at Scripps
she's a medicinal chemist by training or
chemical biologist well they sort of
there's a hot Venn diagram overlaps and
Jun has founded two companies and she's
also sort of the the scientific mover
and shaker in this site of Indy BIOS
incubator and Indy bio incubates
startups in health tech and food tech
and many other interesting texts that
all in one way or the other touch upon
biology hence the name a little known
fact about Jun is that she also has a
clothing line which I was not aware of
and in the happy hour you
talk to her about that and last but not
least Laura 10 deskey Laura has been a
protein biochemists at Novartis most
recently and presently but at its
predecessor companies for dare I ask
thirtyish years and Laura Laura knows
the guy who invented PCR polymerase
chain and that reaction and she was
involved in the project first
characterized the Hep C virus she's been
she's on patents and has been involved
in the development of multiple
successful oncology drugs and yet the
other thing she is that's half her life
the other half of her life that she does
in parallel is she's a mosaics and an
embroiderer and a painter and her art
informs her science and her science
informs her art and so someone with
great perspective so let me consult my
notes here so we have a number of
questions that we wanted to delve into
but first I was going to just mention
and lay out a groundwork for the first
question which is a discussion of
austerity in science so in the history
of science it's been done by different
people in different cultures in
different ways historically much of I
think what academic science looks like
today still has echoes of the medieval
European universities so we're we're you
know the researchers the doctors of
philosophy were actually minor clerics
of the church and it was interesting
because they also were judged by the
church laws not by the secular laws so
there was this historic privilege given
to universities in the Western tradition
and I think we still see echoes of
clerical state in science today that's
certainly how I felt about my personal
life when I was a grad student but it's
it's there there is this this this
culture of austerity but what does it
look like
it looks like in many ways a discussion
of how scientists should just be happy
to do science and they should be slaving
away at the lab and if you think of pop
cultural images of like the mad
scientist there monomaniacal they're
looking at one thing obsessively but in
truth it's nothing like that
however the culture of scientific
training and the pressures within
science to become a professor were to go
a standard route actually select against
people like this group here who've all
taken creative different routes and
selects for people that want to check
boxes and follow a certain linear path
and I'd like to start off by discussing
you know we're all we're you all have
seen that and you know what to you and
I'll start with June maybe because she's
holding the microphone
what do you is is is an example of
scientific austerity that's like baked
into the culture absolutely I say a lot
of it through my entire grad school
program and then seeing a lot of that
happening ongoing is you know it is in
some ways compared to a Ponzi scheme
these days that like you have professors
that need workers to do all of the tasks
and having a person pipette is cheaper
than buying a robot that pipettes and
the robot still breaks down a lot so
hopefully your person doesn't break down
but in essence what they do is they yeah
and you know you're holding like a PhD
in front of dangling in front of them
and and they of course themselves are
interested in contributing to science
they got into science for a reason to
begin with right but even in my own PhD
I felt that I was thinking about like
less than 5% of the time and just doing
very generic grunt work 95% of the time
taking care of mice is the worst like I
did that for two years and it was awful
and like it's you know there's a little
bit of like set up as like a rite of
passage like you have to go through this
in order to be a scientist and
and I really don't think that's true and
I think how you actually really become a
scientist is to close that iteration
cycle write the design test build cycle
and the faster you can go through those
cycles the faster you can learn and then
and then build on top of that so but I
think the way we currently train
scientists is not that and it's it's
it's a little bit more structured saying
you do XY and z and and this is just
what you need to do versus I have an
idea I'm gonna test this and go go try
it out and if that doesn't work I'm
gonna try something else out so it I
think it does hamper innovation
definitely within the individual because
you're not allowed at times to explore
different things either via budget
either via time pressure either either
via your professor telling you what you
can and can't do as projects and yeah so
I think people once they get out of that
environment - they face a lot of
challenges thinking that academia and
perpetuating this Ponzi scheme is the
only way to continue but only 5% of PhDs
end up with academic positions because
we don't have that many new University
springing up everywhere and so we have a
glut of talent who are highly trained
highly driven but with nowhere to go oh
and that's kind of the heart of indie
bio - is we want to adopt all those x
95% of the people and say hey you can
start your lab you can do your science
do the thing that you were passionate
about but let's try to find a different
model go for VC funding instead of
academia funding go for customers and
producing a product versus just writing
a paper yeah so Jun you know one thing
that you said that was really
interesting and strikes home is spending
95% of the time not thinking but doing
things like putting pipette tips and
racks and things like that and which
brings the sort of the question of
Education versus training and Robin
lives this everyday like what is
education versus training and I think
the Minerva project spends a lot of time
trying to educate
and not train so you do you have
perspectives on this culture of
austerity and how one might overcome it
yeah it's so interesting because I
listen to Joon speak and I talked to a
lot of students who get admitted to our
undergraduate program and they're
interested in science and they're really
excited about it and the question they
always ask is well where are your labs
and then when we talk about what they
want to get out of the lab experience it
it isn't that it isn't sitting and
putting you know drops into test tubes
and things like that and it's not
conducting experiments where it's
formulaic I mean the beauty of science
is it's about discovery but we teach
science so often as here's a formula and
here's the reaction you should get and
if you don't get that you did it wrong
so the question then is how do you teach
science in a completely different way
well it's actually the way you should
educate everyone regardless of
discipline and that is thinking about
how do you critically look at the
situation that you have how do you break
it down or we have some students here in
the audience so they guys are gonna say
this is what we do but how do you break
it down what is the right problem what
are you trying to solve for how do you
break it to component parts how do you
test how do you develop hypotheses test
challenge repeat it's it is so much more
about the thinking than the actual doing
and when we think about educating we
think about really educating people
across all disciplines meaning how do
you think critically how do you become a
creative problem solver how do you work
effectively in teams because some of the
best science and discoveries don't
happen in isolation how do you
communicate well because you may have
the best idea but if people don't
understand it then it can't go anywhere
so we think about what are the skills
you need as a scientist and how do we
train for those and where we worry less
about you know the formula for a certain
experiment so that's quite refreshing
thank you I I think that that does lead
to sort of the application side of
things so I'm really curious Fatma about
your perspective
because you you went through the sort of
the traditional you know PhD education
and at some point you said some of you
you just said I want to take the risk of
starting my own company and with all
that entails which is all manner of
difficulty you know reputational
financial so forth
how did the conditions of the academic
world inform your decision to do that I
should start saying I totally agree with
June the experience I was fortunate in
some ways I had a really great PhD
experience my PhD advisor really cared
about his students and I actually got
the learning I didn't actually have to
do the pipetting he didn't really have
too much resources but I actually did
experiment and I had really great
mentors I learned how to do science I
really liked it and I really enjoyed it
and I thought oh I should definitely do
a postdoc and move into a different
field from molecular biology to
chemistry now that was good and bad
decision because different disciplines
have different cultures and particularly
in medical school
I'm not bad-mouthing it's it was a new
learning there I actually experienced a
Ponzi scheme because I think there were
so many students so many actually
motivated students I think more than
they wanted and College of Ag they
didn't really have that many students so
whatever they had they cherish them well
you have abundance of it then one day I
realized like June said the Ponzi scheme
and there wasn't in the future and I
thought I want to do testing and I know
it has a potential what I discovered how
can I do it and I thought we are very
resourceful that is one of the thing you
learn when you are a PhD because you
don't really have resources and I was
very fortunate to be introduced in Dubai
oh and right at the same time we got
SBIR
is one funding thanks to my PhD advisor
who taught me how to get funding and it
taught me how to write grants and how to
organize then I started my company one
thing I should mention what Robin said I
had undergraduate students I had this
training grant and I actually trained my
students and one of them got into a
Medical School
she said hey Dr Kaplan I got into the
school because of your teaching during
the interview everything I learned in
your lab all of the experience I had in
your lab I told them that was the only
thing she comes back just as she got it
and she's in Lewis cots now I can't
really temple Medical School and she was
very varied initially and I thought you
were very smart just be yourself and
that was the science experience in many
ways moving into industry was the best
thing I have ever done I wish I had done
it as soon as I graduated the that's a
really very interesting perspective and
I may have agree with you on the
industry thing myself now that isn't to
say that academia is bad it's just it's
not for everyone
and one one thing you know circling back
to this idea of overcoming austerity and
science and especially fluctuating
austerity laura has worked in in the
biotech industry for longer than most of
us I think and has seen it all the
triumphs and and and the layoffs and the
rehiring xand and I was going to ask
what is your perspective been regarding
cultures where you've worked because the
culture has varied all the time at
Novartis and its predecessor companies
over the years what were successful
scientific cultures and what were less
successful ones really good question
it's interesting because when I started
working I basically worked in the same
place ever since I was in school I got
the job and I always thought I would
quit if
would look for another job if I didn't
like it and I have never looked for
another job and it's because it's never
been boring it changes basically every
two years the technology changes
everything changes culture changes
projects change I've worked on
infectious disease that worked on
oncology and that's the nice thing about
being a protein chemist everybody needs
protein chemistry and as far as culture
goes by far the best projects that I've
worked on have been people who groups
where basically everybody's a leader you
could be a a grad student that's in
there or a postdoc in a meeting and you
get listened to just as readily as
anybody else it's it's a the groups that
are collaborative are the best I've been
on really bad project groups where you
get basically one leader who says my way
or the highway and and that's just not
creative one thing I've realized is and
I encourage people to do students and
something that I did I actually don't
have a PhD I have a bachelor's in
biochemistry and at one point I'm like
okay should I quit and go get a PhD and
I looked around at the jobs that PhD
people did and the jobs that the
quote-unquote technicians do and my
personality fits so much better with the
technician and I like if you look at my
art it's all very repetitive its mosaic
it's it's and so I paid attention to
what makes me happy instead of trying to
put myself in a hole but when it you
know in a round hole but I'm actually
square type of you know so I really
tried to find what made me happy but as
far as cultures go yeah I have seen a
lot of things
my favorite culture are these just
wonderful collaborations I've been in
some pretty bad cultures where one
person came a leader of the company came
in he was there for about five years and
he would pit scientists against each
other and and they wouldn't know it it
was horrible
so they would get the same project to
one group and another group and they
would find out because they were both
working with our group and there'd be
tears and it would it was just
absolutely horrible and that's not good
industry that's not good scientists I
think collaboration and working together
you're going to be able to this
competition is ridiculous makes me angry
but yeah I've seen all kinds of
different styles in the last 30 years in
the same company thanks Laura I was
going to you know Nick in his role
interacts with the whole arc of science
and engineering and design types from
the lone genius to the people who's
whose work is best understood as a group
effort with with equal contribution and
I would just ask broadly what's what
have you observed culturally in the
scientists that you've collaborated with
that long now is collaborated with and
where would you like to see changes or
improvements in general that's a tough
question because I don't know the full
backgrounds of all the different
individuals and groups that we work with
but I think the thing that draws a lot
of people to the long now foundation and
the ideas that were kind of cultivating
is this sense that austerity doesn't
grant you permission to explore the
things that you want to explore makes
you feel constrained it's not exactly
fun it's not exactly the best educated
experience and that in some sense
everyone that's kind of constellated
around the foundation believes that
having more time is good for a certain
set of problems and so there are
problems in which austerity works
optimization works you want to get them
done fast get them out of the way but
there's a whole other set of problems
out there in the world that benefit from
having additional resources temporal
financial whatever it is and so adapting
yourself optimally to one set of
challenges leaves you vulnerable at this
other level of abstraction these other
kinds of challenges and so culturally in
the broader sense you know we're very
well adapted to things like the business
quarter and we're very poorly adapted to
challenges that just don't exist on that
time scale so things like climate change
or space exploration these these
phenomena exist at another level of
abstraction that we just haven't really
adapted ourselves well to and so kind of
how do you diversify temporal
preferences across you know all of these
different time spans for us it's you
know as much as ten thousand years out
in the future because it changes the way
you think about things you know if I
said you know for your business
challenges or you just take world hunger
for example if somebody said can you
solve world hunger in five years you it
would make a lot of sense to be
completely paralyzed by that challenge
and not necessarily know what to do or
you think about the SDGs and even the
timescales that they're on this is this
can be paralyzing for a lot of people
whereas if I said you know could you
solve world hunger in five hundred years
well you your brain starts to operate it
starts to worry away and you start to
thinking maybe the first couple of
meetings that you're gonna have kind of
what direction you're gonna take your
year on and so you start feeling a sense
of agency restored as opposed to feeling
like you can't be an agent like you
can't be in control you don't have
permission to try things explore and so
we're trying to kind of push back
against a certain kind of temporal
austerity in the culture on a whole
thanks that's that's really an
interesting way of looking at it
resources time as the resource that you
really cannot buy and I think we often
undervalue it and to our individual and
collective peril and so yeah that's a
thank you very much for bringing that
perspective to the table now we're
talking about the culture of science and
and reimagining how you know well
looking at what it looks like now and
what it what it could look like and I
think that can't be discussed without
looking at stereotypes and thinking
about how scientists portray themselves
I must say and also how they're
portrayed sometimes fairly sometimes
unfairly in pop culture you know the
cartoon strip scientists who has all
these colored beakers by the way most
things in lab are
my parents once asked me what I did for
a living and I sarcastically told that
my transfers small volumes of clear
liquid into other small volumes of clear
liquid and something invisible is
happening that I indirectly detect and
they haven't really asked me since then
you know but but but but really like you
know there's there's there's an
important aspect I think in encouraging
people to go into science who are more
cognitively diverse than the person that
finishes undergrad and says to
themselves I want to be a tenure track
professor at a top ten research school
and I want to get there in you know 15
years and that's what I want to do with
my life you know a certain type of
person does say that but are those
always the people that bring interesting
discoveries to the table especially
people who might look at things
differently than those very linearly
minded individuals that know they want
that and and so I'm going to ask the
panel about how one might reimagine the
culture of science and and maybe first
though ask what do you think is wrong or
less ideal about the portrayal of
scientists and and how does that
interact with what you know about
yourself or your circle of collaborators
and friends in the field and just
discuss that and I think I might start
with June just to sort of evenly spread
um so I actually think that scientists
is actually really diverse because
especially in the u.s. we have a lot of
international students so like and also
in biology we're actually really
fortunate to have almost a 50/50 split
in women which is really awesome I
actually would flip it on its head that
we actually are so diverse that at times
we can't even find each other because we
just we look normal like all of you
presumably a lot of you are scientists
you look perfectly normal whereas like
in the text Silicon Valley sphere you
know you there's like the tech bro
stereotype and and that's you know cool
for them because they get to like find
their people in some ways I feel like
the scientists were like really spread
out and we're like actually in you know
different pockets and doing our own
thing that was one of the ideas around
my clothing brand actually which I don't
know why I'm not wearing today is is to
try to especially get women to wear
little things to show that they're
scientists to to just appear in public
more so that you that the general public
who are not scientists don't see
scientists as like the Einstein looking
crazy hair old man and some lab doing
crazy stuff you know maniacally tweaking
the world or something but that to
really get out there to say that hey
scientists are around you all the time
we're very diverse from all kinds of
cultures we there's so many women in
science as well and to kind of bring
that conversation just just a quick
thing one thing I've noticed in the
friends that I've made and also looking
at myself pretty much every creative
scientist that I work with is is also
some sort of artist some sort of
creative person sometimes people are
portrayed like like Lewis says but most
of us are either a musician or an artist
or or you know and basically you have to
be creative to be a good scientist and I
think people don't really realize that
and I'd like to honor that a little bit
more and and maybe get that message out
there too
sorry I didn't use my it's gonna ask
Robin you see so many students and you
help to write design curricula that tie
together the sciences with with
philosophy and art and and so much a so
much subject matter that brings
something to the table in terms of
providing context and in fact
inspiration for the science and what do
you see the role of image and culture
and science as affecting that work yeah
it's so interesting and I appreciate the
comments of the other panelists who are
maybe more traditionally scientists I'm
probably one in the looser definition
but I think about it all the time
because science in isolation is
essentially a function but it's not
gonna solve some of the greater
challenges and so when we think about
curriculum when I think about educating
students I think about much more
interdisciplinary approach to any kind
of challenges and science being that so
you know when we look at how we design
curriculum we make sure that students
aren't looking at a problem in isolation
so we actually did something kind of
unique I'll give you a very specific
sort of approach we have to our first
year curriculum is instead of saying
you're going to learn chemistry biology
economics take a writing class what we
say is we're gonna talk about problems
like how to feed the world we're gonna
talk about what do we do about the
world's water supply we're gonna ask why
do people commit crimes we're going to
talk about how do you stop war we're
going to talk about really really
complex challenges because if you think
about each of these there's a science
angle there's a social science angle to
it there's an interpersonal connection
to it everything in life is a complex
system and there are second-order and
third-order effects and how you think
about that in a really broad context is
going to make people better scientists
so it really is how do we get out of
that stereotype of a scientist is in
their lab by themselves they're actually
out thinking about how to apply science
in a really practical way
and along those lines I was going to ask
eunuch about in your line of work you
oversee collaborations of all different
sizes and and and how how does culture
play a role in the PIA the cultures of
the participants scientifically and
intellectually and otherwise play a role
in in those collaborations I think back
to the earlier comment that we were
discussing about these other cultures
being um mostly rooted in the idea of
taking the right amount of time for
things that things like creativity
original thinking divergent thinking
there take a bit of an abundance of
resources that our culture doesn't
necessarily support people using all the
time we don't always want to give people
500 years to solve world hunger and
sometimes we expect people to launch and
sell a company and then launch and sell
another one immediately afterwards so
this culture of passing the baton as
opposed to necessarily you know just
kind of dunking the basketball this idea
that you know our cultures are very good
at lifting people up when they are they
are basically starting an idea taking it
to fruition and then closing the whole
thing up and then saying that was great
that's packaged put that in the past
let's try something new and do that
again we're trying to receive this idea
that it can be alright to start projects
without feeling obliged to necessarily
finish them within your lifetime that
there are certain again certain projects
at certain time scales that just won't
be finished within one lifetime or one
you know a couple of business quarters
so how do we make it cool to be the kind
of person or the kind of you know member
of an institution that's just passing
the baton from one stage to the next
whether that's the first stage the last
stage the middle stages how do we get
how do we see that as something that
people aspire to more of like the
maintenance side of the world that we
live in as opposed to just this
innovative like flash of genius
archetype of just like I had a great new
way of doing this it's like well no no
I'm actually helping them do this
awesome thing that they've been doing
for a while so I think that Fatma in her
role as founding a company and putting
together a team I did you in doing this
have to overcome this like individual in
a lab doing great science
to shifting that frame as references
Nick points out to a this is a
team-based product this isn't the the
lone genius archetypical science model
and could you speak to that like what
worked and what didn't
yes that is actually one of our
strengths we work as one as a team and
that is one of the emphases actually
anybody came to our lab if we emphasize
that if somebody falls through the crack
we all fall so one of the reason I do
once a week lab meetings we actually
talk a lot more but once a week I'll
make sure that everyone is same level no
one is falling through cracks and if
someone is behind and will talk and help
them out to be the same level so that
that I do care and everyone one other
thing I taught everyone is time
management I don't manage anyone's time
everyone manages their own time but I
was the expert initially how the
experiments were done and I taught them
and I did that actually even before I
started in my company I when I was doing
masters and I had group of
undergraduates the first two months I
taught them how to manage their time and
how to do this experiment then they
recruited their own friends and next
thing I know they're teaching each other
and they were working so well then I
moved on to another project and I asked
them for help and I said well here is
one of the thing I need help they said
when can you do it they said well here
is our schedule we can give it to you
two weeks later and I said God now I
knew two weeks later I was gonna have
what I needed and same thing with my lab
and when they need it to have time they
said well here's the experiment this is
the time it's gonna be ending we would
like to have a break and I said sure so
what are the things you need help while
you're on vacation so your experiment
would be going and they said well if we
don't really need any help we finish it
on this day we come back when we come
back our experiment is going to be ready
and I said yes I can't really ask
anything more then we can do more
creative stuff
we work as a whole if somebody needs you
know there are sometimes maintenance
couple of things here and there they
said well I talked to this person and
who's gonna be helping me out when I'm
gone and then I come back I can pick up
where I left thank you I can put in a
bit of perspective from my own
experience so you know in my graduate
work in my postdoc I worked in friendly
collaborative labs but labs where each
each trainee had their own project and
there were sort of boxes drawn around
those so you know sometimes the project
was lucky if it was novel biology
sometimes you'd get lucky sometimes it
would turn out to be much harder than it
it it appeared at first glance and this
was good for for enforcing self-reliance
but it was not an efficient way to
discover new things and and and maybe
its purpose wasn't but that model is the
very large sort of big research academia
driven vehicle for doing basic research
in much of the world including the US
and what was really refreshing about and
you may laugh at me about this but it
was really refreshing about joining Big
Pharma is that everything was a
team-based effort and for the most part
teams were rewarded together and also
called to accountability together and
this to me was very refreshing and it
actually it had an interesting effect on
making the internal research more
reproducible because if you were a
single contributor and your output our
scientific papers and the higher impact
journal scientific papers the better you
might oversell the value of what you
discovered or maybe omit some key
control experiments and this can make it
much more difficult for people to build
on what you've published but inside a
company where other people are depending
upon the work that you're doing right
next to them to help build an edifice
that needs to work in its entirety
there's an opposite selective pressure
if anything people under under played
their results because they wanted to be
absolutely sure that those were
reproducible so I know that big pharma
is not always held up as a place where
you know everyone thinks great science
is done but
really great science is done there often
and one of those reasons is because of
this team environment but the other
perspective moving from the like
individual contributor to science as a
team affair is what I found working for
a small start-up is there's only two of
us in a company now that's like 13 or 14
people that had industry experience and
so it's been a fun and interesting
cultural effort to change the culture of
the company and say okay you know we
need to actually coordinate our
schedules and manage time and and view
our successes and failures as a team
effort and I really think I think that
that's key and and I'll also mention
that maybe the subject of a future panel
or event we're going to do is think
about instances where credit for science
is not divided the way it maybe ought to
be rosalind Franklin an x-ray
crystallographer and one of the co
discoverers of the DNA structure is a
prime example of maybe someone who
didn't get credit for many reasons
notably the Nobel Prize can't be split
more than three ways but if you look at
the research underlying any given Nobel
Prize there's probably 20 or 50 or a
hundred or more people who've
contributed to that so you know
something to think about so I've a few
Mon Li two more questions and then we'll
we'll mingle and and do some somewhat
directed small talk and Yin who's
organized this event will will explain
that but each of you is a really complex
individual as we all are and in in
looking at a group of science scientists
and science enabling and oriented people
I wanted to ask this question which is
if you're if you're an iceberg there's a
tip of you sticking out of the ocean and
then there's the larger volume that's
underneath and you know in this these
times you might be mostly molten but I'd
like you know maybe each of you to say
what's the tip of your iceberg that
people see you and if they were to draw
a caricature
what would they seize upon
and then what's the part of you that's
that's that's deep and large volume
under the surface
how what whoever wants to let's see the
tip of the iceberg that's interesting
I've changed so much in the last three
years I'm I'm a lot different than the
way I used to be I used to be terribly
shy and now basically I wear sparkly
things clothes art that that I have made
and a lot more visible so I would say
the the most visible is the artist in me
down deep is probably more the science
actually so and Nick I just wanted to
when you were talking about making it
cool to be to work on things that might
take longer than a lifetime I thought
about Sagrada família are you familiar
with that gorgeous gorgeous and Gaudi
started it and it was finished I think
125 years later and it's just a
beautiful example of that kind of
cooperation even before being completed
it is so beautiful so and that that's
really I think this idea of projects
that are greater than an individual
person that you contribute to do your
best but you might not see the end of
when I worked in farmer that's kind of
my approach to all the projects I was on
and and indeed the division whose work I
mostly supported infectious diseases was
shut down for business reasons but you
know we're releasing the data to the
public and the work will go on so this
idea there is an element of scientific
culture that is looking at these long
timelines and saying can I be if I if I
don't worry about my own ego
can I be part of something that's
impactful and long-term and a meta
structure that many people have
contributed to so that's a really cool
point Laura all right I'll go I think if
you look at the tip of the iceberg where
most people have seen me the last seven
years or so it's out talking about
Education innovation in education and
I'm very often out and about around the
world and that's what people see but I
think what is below the surface is I am
a mom I care a lot about my family my
kids and that kind of grounds me and the
piece that a lot of people don't know is
I am really a wanderer
so whereas I'm very very directed in
what I do and people always say you know
type-a goal-driven
but my background in the past had a lot
of travel in it and I really believe
that life is not about just knowing
where you want to get to but it's
actually taking the journey and taking a
lot of side tracks inside paths and
getting off the road that everybody else
is on and trying different things and if
you look at my career it isn't as direct
as anybody would think there's sort of
every piece there's lots of layers thank
you
there's lots of layers to everything and
I think that's the piece that's below
the surface that no one sees so it seems
like my turn
well on the surface everybody knows here
I have a startup and I am an
entrepreneur and scientist so that would
be the visible part I think the
invisible part I'm a human and I love my
family and I'd like to spend time with
them and I like the community and I
believe the strong community creates a
strong relationships and I care about
people and I'd like to bond with people
and I like socializing I am a social
person so I think I am like everybody
else and we all care about each other
and making friends that would be day
bigger than me part
um I think I'm the surface when people
find out that I work for the long now
foundation and they have some
familiarity with some of our projects
that are kind of moonshot projects on
large timescales for building a clock
inside of a mountain that'll last for
10,000 years with no human intervention
and working at the extinct the woolly
mammoth genomic technology and landing a
language archive on a comment these are
like really fun things to say here on a
dais cuz they sound a really cool and
really amazing and there's some really
cool people involved in it and so I
think on the surface a lot of times
people think that's probably the coolest
part of the job or something and I'm
really paying attention to but the truth
is like I get so much more pleasure and
having conversations with people who are
inspired to work on really interesting
things but just haven't taken off yet
you don't know their name yet I don't
know they're you know I'm meeting them
in the context of you know an event or
you know a cocktail party or an event
like this and I think that's just
fascinating to find what people are
dedicating their lives to are leaving
academia because they just feel so
strongly this project needs to be worked
on and if it needs to be in the private
space let's take it to the private space
or if we need to reinvent education
models like let's just do it it's so
important we have to do it so I'm
constantly inspired by the people that
are around me working on these really
interesting things
yeah and that just like gives me a lot
of hope for the future and yeah that
wouldn't necessarily be on the surface
people probably like oh yeah how many
times you've been at the clock this week
zero finally I think about this so on
the tip of the iceberg a scientific
director here at Indy bio helping
companies helping scientists become
entrepreneurs and realizing their dream
and build innovation in the world some
of the personal reasons for that
underneath one is that because I was a
scientist who became an entrepreneur and
so I want to bring get more scientists
to bring their science into the world
secondly that you know as a nerd girl
growing up I was picked on as being like
really into science and but now I'm like
out there saying like science is really
cool so like trying to bring that joy of
science into the world and and
to get people to pay attention to it
because as we know science literacy is
not so great in America and that has led
to a lot of political issues and I want
more people to embrace science to think
about it as you know a you know valid
obviously in the world and and to think
more logically and and come to some of
their own conclusions themselves and
then on the other side of just like
seeing entrepreneurship and help helping
see entrepreneurship I'm just so
fascinated by human ingenuity like
everything you see in this room was
created by people we you know started it
as cavemen and now we have everything
and we're you know curing diseases and
and hacking our own genetics right we
are changing using our technology it
should change the evolutionary processes
in which we are genetics are now
selected for and and that has a lot of
responsibility that could go very well
or go very badly but we are shepherding
that and we're building technologies for
that and then on the very last personal
level you know I want to be healthy and
potentially live a long time and so um
trying to expand health span and
longevity and then that also goes into
climate change because if you know
climate change doesn't revert in the
next couple of you know decades we're
not gonna have a great home on this
planet either so all these things are
pressing issues that we are gonna be
facing and I'll I'll put in on the
surface I'm really interested and people
know my interest in finding new chemical
matter encoded by the genome of nature
and how do we how do we do this more
efficiently how do we hunt
amid the meta-genome to find new enzymes
that do new chemistry that's useful
sometimes medicinally sometimes for for
material science purposes and and this
is CSO of bolt thread is joining us
tonight and what both threads has done
is exactly that they prospected in
metagenomic space found a really useful
of protein and how to manipulate it and
how to engineer it and they're making an
entirely new material that the humanity
did not have access to before
so my you know day job and a lot of my
extra time has spent thinking about
these things but what most people don't
know about me is for fun
outside of science I read quite a bit of
fairly obscure history well I started
with the less obscure but I I'm a
student of history and and with a
particular interest in how people's how
societies collective worldviews about
certain subjects shifts over time and
and sometimes it shifts really quickly
and sometimes it's really slow and you
know I wouldn't you know there's
heterogeneity in it and yet at the same
time there's themes in in understanding
human nature and how how groups of
humans make decisions that I think we
learn from history but now we're at this
interesting point where I don't think
people have fundamentally changed yet
the technology at our disposal has
changed quite a bit some would say it's
still changing exponentially and you
know how do we I spend a lot of time
because of that thinking about how do we
traverse this exciting but dangerous
period where we can bend biology and
science to the service of humanity we
can bend it to the service of of may be
reversing some of the damage we've done
to the earth but doing so will take away
some people's jobs if we do it well
it'll take everyone's away everyone's
need to work to subsist but how do we
transition through that middle period
where some people are employed some
people aren't and robotics have taken
their jobs or bioengineering has taken
their jobs so so I think that that
that's that's the thing that people
don't know about me as I spend a lot of
time thinking about history what we
learn about people from things that have
happened in history and how we can use
those learnings as we go forward and
question
yeah so so first I wanted to think we'll
do the questions I wanted to thank all
the panelists who've you know come out
on a weekday night and and you know done
us the honor of their presence and their
perspective most of all and I hope you
all see from this panel that their
science scientific culture has
heterogeneity and and and diversity and
there's many determinants of culture and
the lives of scientists that are
important to consider I'd also like to
thank yen Lu who's in the back he's the
program director and essentially founder
of bio captivate and we're doing this as
an experiment you are a select set of
invited guests who are part of our
experiment but but yin put this together
and we're really curious what you all
think about it
and I'd like to thank nd bio for hosting
I'd like to thank the other bio
captivate co-conspirators who can't be
with us tonight but helped Keira havens
Chris Oaks and Ian Hayden and so we're
going to this is going to evolve and
we'll see where it goes some upcoming
things that we don't have the schedules
nailed down is we want we want to look
at some narratives in science some
specific narratives and do maybe some
deeper dives for instance into the life
of rosalind Franklin the co-discoverer
of DNA structure and maybe also do some
some discussions of specific techniques
society societal problems like you know
what did we really learn from the human
genome project and how has that affected
general culture so stay tuned those
sorts of things are coming and sometimes
we'll have panels sometimes we'll have
salons sometimes we'll have happy hours
sometimes we'll have lectures I gave a
talk to us that I we can make available
online in the past about why DNA is not
computer coding or computer codes so
things like that so we want to stimulate
you and and and actually have you help
us come up with what is a playbook for
communicating science
in these times so without further ado we
have interesting panelists we have
someone who's waiting to ask a question
Mario let's get started
questions so something I was just
thinking about listen you guys speak you
know we want to get more people involved
in science and you know like you how do
we get more women involved in science
how do we get you know disenfranchised
people involved in science how do we get
people from different backgrounds
involved how do we you know address the
two different kinds of genius now we you
know really have the flash genius in
mind but there's the slow genius and
that's kind of what the long now
foundation kind of caters to and I'm
wondering if you guys think you're an
artist three two so I'm wondering you
know how do you guys think about it in
the lens of inclusivity because when I
think about it it's like all of these
things can be viewed through the lens of
just opening up opportunities to more
people to get involved and kind of shine
in the lens of science so you know it's
not a word that's come up yet but I'm
wondering if that's something you guys
think about in terms of you know your
mission well I can speak for bio captive
agency it's a yes and we really want to
encourage people to think about science
even if their day job is something else
because we're all scientists and and we
have to make policy decisions at the
very least people should understand some
science but it's also fun to participate
in and I know what you're doing with
counterculture labs Mario is right in
the midst of encouraging people who
might not otherwise be involved with
science to become citizen scientists and
so bio captivate you know definitely
encourages that I'd say I'd like to ask
the panelists if anyone has some
perspectives on Mario's question and
comment
I see join us startup because pretty
much every bio startup is gonna have
multiple functions right you need
operations business people you might
need marketing and now it's also we're
seeing that biotech is now a technology
just like the tech sector it's booming
in all areas of different sectors so you
know there's transportation companies
there's food companies there's neuro
tech there's all kinds of different
things so I think that's a great way for
someone who
might not be traditionally embedded in
science to get in and learn science and
once they're there you know they're
gonna take that experience and go
elsewhere with that so in our case
science is not very easy to communicate
but we finally got a project we're very
excited about it is aspirin imitate some
of you might have the mission patch when
I used to say nematodes before you say
oh yeah interesting and then next thing
you know the attention disappeared what
this one you say hey you're sending
limited space and listen tell me more
about it why are you sending them to
space so it is a great project and we
made its own website and we are trying
to include as much as many people as we
can and we already got invited to give a
talk for actually it is for the San
Francisco high school and I thought this
is a really great project one of the
reason is when you're a kid you always
think about something when I was a kid
well I was gonna go to Disneyland I
never even thought about sending
limiters to space doing experiment in
space can I actually dream about it can
I actually imagine if you imagine and
dream you can't do it but how could you
do something you couldn't even imagine
well even if you did imagine it's so far
away can you actually reach to it so we
taught with this project we can actually
include everyone
it's a project we share with everyone so
the project has its own website its
Twitter so we will be updating every one
if you want to be part of it we have
IndieGoGo campaign to put your name
there as part of the mission partners so
you're very excited because it's the
first signed project science project I
can share it everyone I'll answer really
quick and I'll just say that part of it
is just exposure I mean that's the
question like how do you get people more
excited about science it's about giving
people an opportunity in a safe space
and I think about most universities and
if you go into some of the intro science
classes they're all considered
the filter classes right this is for the
students who want to go to med school
and typically people hate those classes
they're just grind and you know how do
you reimagine I mean it's something we
did how do you reimagine the sciences
and have every single student get
exposed to it it doesn't mean they're
all gonna major in it it doesn't mean
they're all gonna become scientists but
they certainly understand it they
understand what experiments are about
they understand how to think about
datasets they think about logic in terms
of planning out how you're going to
approach a challenge so I think it's
it's incumbent upon us to require it and
I think it starts early we happen to do
it at the college level start earlier
get students excited about science early
and make it approachable absolutely and
I'm really excited to start
collaborating with a lot of people on
the art level my friend Greg bilqis back
there is we're going to be collaborating
basically using art to introduce science
I was talking to a friend he's a grad
student and he says that when people
find out oh you're a biochemist it's
like an intimidating word like oh you're
you're some crazy person that I can't
talk to because you speak a different
language and in some ways that's true
but in a lot of ways that's not it took
me five minutes to explain the concept
of PCR to Greg and he's a smart guy and
he completely understands it and she
sees the artistry of it and the just the
beauty of it and bringing bringing
science to everyone through art I'm
really really really excited about it
and it's it's it's just a different way
of communicating it and I'll echo what
Robyn said about exposure we think
that's so important and it's a long now
foundation we have a speaking series
here in San Francisco we actually have
two speaking series but one of them in
SF jazz one of them at our spot the
interval which is up on the North
Waterfront but we take both of them we
record them and we send them out as
podcasts we're gonna be releasing a
bunch of this talk these talks is
YouTube videos for everybody to access
they're currently up on our website and
we get about a million people tuning in
to those every single year and I get
some really interesting emails from
people all over the country
all over the world who are not
scientists they have jobs as truck
drivers or schoolteachers or any other
job you can imagine and they'll send
things in and talk about oh my god and
this doctor blew my mind and now I've
been down a rabbit hole and you know
with the internet kind of augment
people's exposure to these ideas people
can really kind of ramp up their own
education and things and I think we had
talked a little bit about how so many of
the interesting things you find that
inform your science are other things
like art or other fields of study like
history they kind of start to inform the
way you're thinking about it and so yeah
so you have a question I do well I have
a common first which is thank you
everyone for coming out here this is
excellent I really appreciate this salon
people thinking about things and I don't
know taking their precious time on a
weeknight to do this now I'm asking a
question kind of on behalf of my younger
self looking at the system it seems like
most people that you talk to they'll be
appalled to know how small the NSF
budget is it's like a fraction of a
percent and it's ridiculous
if you were to really and again I say
asked us on the behalf of my younger
self because I remember being kind of
like naive and not understanding how
long things take and asking you know
what would we really expect to come out
of the system if most of the money comes
from creating you know clever financial
products that's where people are going
to go
it seems pretty ridiculous to expect
that anything different is going to
happen so Nick I really like what you
said about having a different
perspective and I'm wondering if as kind
of a challenge to you guys as leaders in
this space what would you recommend to
all of the highly motivated and talented
people out here what would you actually
do to change the second and third-order
terms in this function if you really
wanted this to change if you wanted to
put more money into science you wanted
to tell people that academia is not just
a Ponzi scheme but that it is very
creative and you could do things how
what sorts of instructions would you
give to people to go into this to not
make the rational decision which is you
know yeah you know go into like
management and take
ready for other people's work or I don't
know invest in things that are probably
make money or start a startup and then
sell it to Novartis no no offense I
think Novartis is a great company but
realistically I'm wondering like as a
challenge to you guys what would you
tell people to make real changes to like
the second and third order terms in this
function how do you make sure that we
don't continue doing this thing at a
really slow pace and you know see what
we've been seeing for the last 100 years
or so I think that people should really
pursue what they're passionate about and
and I think society has an especially
you know parents and culture have really
told us like go to school to get that
good job the school is the means to that
end
and same with your PhD it's like well it
doesn't exactly matter what I work on
because I just want a PhD or like oh now
I'm gonna go into a postdoc doing
something a little bit different versus
just having more of a clear idea saying
like I want to solve this problem I want
to end cancer I want to you know figure
out how Alzheimer's works and and then
going and finding how to get there
so it's yeah it's definitely a balance
and I think it's economically driven
because we all have to eat and so
sometimes an economic option and that
safety net is more attractive than going
after and taking those risks but if you
can find ways to creatively get to what
you're actually passionate about as fast
as possible by taking it as little risk
as possible then definitely try that
math so I would I would echo Jun
especially on the temporal advice like
you know try to succeed or fail at
something or determine you like
something or don't like it quickly and
then get on with your life and and and
continue doing these experiments in
terms of how we change this for instance
how scientists are compensated or
how science is incentivized that's more
complicated merely increasing the budget
for science education probably won't
help actually the NIH budget
around the turn of the millennium
infamously doubled and a lot of that
doubling went into you know more grant
money which encouraged more junior
faculty to positions to be created but
those junior faculty needed the Pyramid
of grad students and postdocs to
assemble under them to produce data
which produce papers which gets more
grant money so pretty soon the money was
insufficient and they were just you know
twice as many people running in that
particular you know experiment but so so
just just increasing the funding and
maybe isn't enough restructuring it
though could help and there's been a lot
of discussion of this among people who
talk about the postdoc ellipse at the
postdoc a cop apocalypse there's
somewhere on the order of 80 or a
hundred thousand people with PhDs
circulating around from from postdoc
appointment to postdoc appointment we're
just leaving the workforce because you
know they they don't they don't see a
way out where they don't have a way out
into a job that they feel fits their
education or a career that fits their
education so maybe incentivizing
universities not to harvest grant money
and perpetuate the pyramid scheme in the
way that they do but instead say let's
have smaller laboratories where a
professor has a high-paid maybe one
highly paid postdoc maybe one research
assistant professor or senior technician
associated with them and and just
changed the structure from of our
science from mega labs to mom-and-pop
you know labs the Canadian research
system largely looks like that with some
exceptions to give you sort of a
personal idea you know a to give you an
idea of how Aust your things can be when
I was a postdoc at UCSF the standard
salary was 42 K ere try living on that
and I was like oh man what have I done
wrong in life I'm like almost 30 and I
have to live with random roommates and
like you know can't afford to do
anything so it's you know that that's a
problem but it also comes from the
scientists narratives that they tell
selves and what they tell the public if
you're a research scientist and you're
not producing fraudulent research and
there's a fair bit of that you're making
something that is real you are actually
making something and it has value and
other people can build upon it and I
think that there should be this act
there should be a more vocal discussion
among scientists that they deserve you
know a middle-class lifestyle in return
for what they're giving to the society
what they're producing and I think that
often scientists tell each other and I
ran into this all the time even in Big
Pharma oh how dare you suggest that you
know our our salaries aren't in line
with you know the rest of industry in
this field you're just lucky to get to
do science every day and and that's true
but and and very few people get to do
what they want to as their career but it
doesn't mean it should be done in an
exploitative way so I think there is a
need to discuss narrative and there's
also a need to look at not funding only
but the structure of that funding so
sorry that was long-winded other
thoughts question I completely agree
with what you're saying I think it's
totally true I don't think adding more
funding was necessarily helped I guess
what I say is as someone who decided not
to pursue the PhD partly because it
seemed glaringly obvious what was going
to happen I wonder as as leaders as
people that people look to and young
people think well these guys must be
doing something because they understand
the scope of the problem ooh
I challenge you to give people
suggestions for things that they could
actively do in order to change these
things about I say this because
something like for instance the peer
review system as it happens right now is
very clearly broken if you if you're
going to select for studies that create
outstanding publications in nature you
are incentivizing people to do certain
things if as a reviewer of a study I say
this thing is ridiculous I am NOT going
to let it through there's no negative
repercussion
the kinds of studies that we see which
are really interesting like the 2006 you
know induced pluripotent stem cell study
would not have happened if like you know
I'm sure you guys talk to people who
write grants and they all say kind of
the same thing which is you write a
grant for the thing you've already done
so you can use the money to do the thing
you really want to do these things to
people who are in research are very
obvious and young people think that you
guys are taking care of this you're
doing something about it and as an older
person who's an industry now and I look
at it I realize no one's doing anything
about it so again the second third order
terms I challenge you guys as leaders
and I know I'm like you know if shifting
will blind to you but I challenge you to
like galvanize people and really tell
them what can we do to change this
because we shouldn't be surprised by the
results that we're saying sorry for the
rambling challenge accepted and and I
think a lot of us are trying to do that
and I don't pass this along but this is
one of the reasons that I got involved
in bio Captivate because we want people
to understand that maybe we could do
things better for both humanity and for
the scientists themselves and and in
fairness I always try to talk out to
talk people out of going directly to
graduate school from undergrad or
directly from working for me to grad
school and I always say if I write you
this letter and you get in and you're
unhappy four years from now you can't
say I didn't warn you but no part of its
providing good advice but part of it I
think and I maybe haven't done this
loudly enough is to really demand and
write about the change that we we
probably need systemically I totally
agree with you there is one observation
I had in the system is for example Laura
wanted to be a technician I don't think
today any of these students have an
option of being a technician because how
many inertia profs have a technician
when I was in grad school my advisor at
that technician five years later the
technician position eliminated it all
became soft money and many of the grad
students sadly but used as a technician
you know many of the things could have
been done by the technician who would be
very happy but today actually
have an option maybe we should bring
some of the good things in the past and
put it in place many other positions in
between and one other thing I used to do
I used to teach a thousand student class
biology class I was an adjunct lecturer
so my appointment who knows whether it
was gonna happen again that student
would come to me because they would I
used to give a introduction what I did
they would all get excited about it and
I would get visit hey what should I do
and most of the time I don't know what I
would like to do and I said that's quite
okay when I was an undergrad I didn't
know what I wanted to do either but if
this is the project I work and if you
work on it if you like it you know what
you like if you don't like it that is
perfectly fine because you eliminated
one thing that this is something you
don't want to do that is just as
important as what you would like to do
and while the ones who work with me
didn't go away they stay with me but it
is also the environment to how much they
like one other thing I'll add to
everything that's been shared up here is
that I as important as it is to find
what you love and to find a way to do it
sometimes it also involves getting very
creative about doing things that you
don't love to be able to continue to
foster your you know predilections for
obscure history in my case like
philosophy or whatever it is that's a
kind of your side hustle thing that
makes you come alive sometimes you have
to get really creative and there is no
easy way where someone's going to just
hand you the cheque in a sufficient
amount for you to do the thing that you
want to do in the way that you want to
do it and you have to get kind of
ruthless and so just from personal story
because I don't know how to tell anyone
how to do that it's very individual in
my in my experience I came out of
college with an engineering degree in
the Midwest and did not want to work in
engineering because it was very Dilbert
asked
in that world and I was working with an
organization that sold proprietary
fastening components to the domestic
domestic automotive industry
so like patented screws nuts and bolts
this couldn't have been a more boring
job a more soul-crushing job but it was
a sales job and I figured that I could
probably charm my way into working a
decent sales pipeline and set aside all
the extra time for doing what I love
which the time was like being in a rock
band and being a musician and then later
on studying philosophy and so getting
really comfortable with doing something
I absolutely loved very creatively was
what allowed other parts of myself to
not just die and become these background
things I used to do but it kept them
alive and eventually in a weird way on a
longer arc it landed me in a place where
now I get to actually have those
conversations that I've wanted to have
my entire life but man that was a crazy
weird 10-15 year plan that absolutely
wasn't guaranteed shouldn't have worked
out I got very lucky so I guess my
advice is be very like flexible super
creative and get very lucky all right I
have to I have to just follow that with
something because I talked to a lot of
students all the time about how to think
about internships jobs careers and all
of that because it's heavy on their mind
but I want to go back I agree with one
thing Jun said and I'm gonna disagree
with another which kind of builds on on
yours one is you got to figure out what
you care about and it needs to be a
problem a situation you may love science
and you care about science but there may
be some other challenge in the world
find something that you can get excited
about but the one thing you said is
don't take a risk and this is something
that I feel like you have to in life and
I think about I said I have a wandering
path someday we'll have a happy hour
I'll tell you my career if anybody cares
but if I hadn't taken a chance at the
craziest times I mean imagine seven
years ago someone came to me and said
let's go reinvent higher education are
you crazy we're gonna start a university
from scratch there are 4,000 American
colleges and universities why in the
world do we need another but we did and
so sometimes you've got to believe and
take a leap and especially if you're
younger in your career you got more
flexibility before you have obligations
take chances because chances will open
up opportunities
I would like to add one more thing you
don't have to be just young to take the
risk you can be older too huh just
listen to your heart if it is a job that
you really didn't like it it will really
crush your soul slowly slowly slowly and
listen to yourself and am I really happy
can I actually do something else or just
feel it once in a while evaluate how
much you like it because I do it even
though I like what I do
even every couple of months I think
about it do I still like it
do I still move forward or how can I
make it because if you don't like it
when the tough times comes in it's gonna
be really hard but if you're really
passionate about it and if you like it
tough times will come and you'll think
about away so how can I make it happen
okay I have this ten months or five
months can I make it or what can I do
six months later that's gonna get better
and you'll get to see the opportunities
keep your eyes on the opportunities
things doesn't come at the time you
anticipate it comes in but you have
multiple options when you see it grab it
when it shows up so now add I should
miss explain what I was mentioning about
risk I think often times when you are
faced with the risk if you actually
think about all the underlying factors
it's not a risk at all every I've
essentially switched for jobs in six
years and each time there was like am i
leaving this entire field of study that
did my PhD in and I was like you know
that's actually not a big of a risk
let's try it so did that and then you
know started a company that was a huge
risk and then and then ended up here at
any bias so it's yes absolutely take the
risk but I think from the mindset side
if you are scared about something and
you're scared and you have all this fear
if you actually break it down there's
really nothing to fear so I wanted to be
cognizant of the time and give everyone
time to mingle with our panelists and I
know other people might have questions
please pose them individually and
because we want to
time for people to mingle and our
organizer Yin is going to come up and
just briefly explain how he wants us to
make small talk and mingle but not not
the normal small talk not a small talk
without a subject he wants us to
actually focus on meaningful small talk
or subject directed so Yin did you want
to explain that come up here well um
Lito personal story first sight so it
was in 2016 I was volunteering for
organization and I invite Robin to speak
and at the time that I was broke
unemployed and virtually home nice I
mean couchsurfing and also I I graduated
from SFSU with an undergrad degree so
that's basically consider an important
in the eyes of a lot of people in
science but the thing is at the time
that I believe that it's my dream is
something I'm willing to die for it to
change the culture of science and even
for me that like someone who was so
insignificant that can bring people
together and have some kind of impact so
I think is anyone can have impact so
it's like it doesn't matter how small or
insignificant significant you are if
your desire your belief is strong enough
enough then your impact will come out
and also like if Yan can cook some magic
you can cook
so the following section will be the
networking section so actually I would
say no no small talk talk about big
things what's your type what's your
deepest desire what's your deepest
longing like what make you feel alive
and also like our gatherings social
contracts so the thing is like what is
my captive way we create those gathering
that trying to transform trying to help
people to embrace a deeper part of
themselves and trying to achieve
something that they they didn't thing is
possible there are a lot of amazing
people here and so therefore that I I
think that you should talk about not
just your deepest longing but also like
what was lacking like like what do you
need what type of towel and I'll help
opportunity that you won or you need
that like more than likely that um is
someone even just tonight that can
bridge that gap and bring you to your
next chapter and I know that from my own
personal experience that there's only
one thing in life that truly matter is
how to go to the next chapter how to
change the rules the ground rules and
the ground rules are everything and so
and also have some print out is those I
call them my news so it's just some some
my favorite quote so you're welcome to
take a peek and and and and pick
something that speak to your heart and
discuss with whoever that that you've
you click and so this is a very good way
to do networking but also like you don't
have to use them you can just take them
home and I think a wonderful quote and
where you transform a transformation No
oh my tears and and then the other thing
is I will encourage you you to talk
about how we can transform the entire
organization know and
intra-organizational relations because
this world is made of relations and also
like how to transform your own relation
with yourself like I was a question
about was your narrative and then what
are your narratives we all have many
narratives and some mutually
incompatible
and some 45 each other so and it is our
own job and also our duty towards others
to kind of open the narrative to help
people to pick out a good narrative
scent and and get rid of the then also
help for once so that's about it thank
you everyone all right thank you
[Music]
let's have some wine and and no small
talk
you